♪♪
-Hey, guys.
Welcome back to the show.
Tonight we're visiting all five
boroughs in New York City,
and right now here in Manhattan
at the world-famous
Madame Tussauds Wax Museum
in Times Square.
Millions of people visit here
every year to see wax figures
of their favorite celebrities,
and I want to have
a little fun with them.
And so does my first guest.
You can see new episodes
of his docuseries,
"More Than an Athlete,"
Thursdays on ESPN+.
Here he is, Michael Strahan.
[ Laughs ]
-Hey, buddy, how you doing?
Hey, everybody! I'm here!
-Michael, you and I have a lot
in common besides our physiques.
-Yeah, I'm wearing
your suit right now.
-We both have wax figures
of ourselves on display
here at Madame Tussauds,
and so I thought it would be fun
to pretend to be our wax figures
and then surprise people.
-Oh, that's fun.
-Ready to do this?
-Let's do it.
♪♪
-Wow. Okay.
-Hey, Jimmy. How are ya?
-I've never seen
the back of my ear.
-Now you're making me look
at the back of my ear.
I've never seen it, either.
Oh, my God. They even got
the crooked finger.
-Wow. That's wild.
-Look at that.
-Hey. You ever held your own
hand with the same hand?
[ Laughter ]
-Okay, folks. This is Tim.
He's your photographer today.
-Hey, guys. Nice to meet you.
You guys big
"Tonight Show" fans?
-Yes.
-Yeah!
-All right. Cool.
All right. So here we go.
And three, two, one.
Big smiles!
[ Camera shutter clicks ]
-That was great.
-[ Shrieks ]
-[ Laughs ]
-Oh, my God!
-That was really good.
[ Laughter ]
-My mom's gonna kill me for
meeting you without telling her!
-[ Laughs ]
-Michael.
-It's so nice to meet you.
Oh, my gosh.
-Hi. Jimmy.
-This is Jimmy.
-You don't think they're just
gonna immediately know it's us?
-For some reason, I think
that we can get away with it.
[ Laughter ]
-Here comes the next contestant.
Take a seat.
Take a seat at the bench.
Yeah. This looks great.
-[ Laughter ]
-You can set down your bags,
yeah.
[ Women scream ]
[ Camera shutter clicks ]
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
-I couldn't hold my face still
any longer!
I'm like, "Oh, my God.
They're onto us."
-All right.
And three, two, one...
[ Slide whistle blows ]
[ Camera shutter clicks ]
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
-Did you know it?
-I knew it!
-Let's have you sit down
on the bench right here.
Beautiful. Cool.
All right.
And three, two, one...
-Catch!
-Oh, my gosh!
-[ Camera shutter clicks ]
-Ohh!
-Oh, my God. I was like...
[ Laughter ]
-How are you?
-He said it looked so real.
We are real. We're here, man.
-We actually are real.
-Here we go.
Three, two, one...
-Yeah!
-Hey!
[ Camera shutter clicks ]
-This is great.
Let's get a real picture.
Come on.
Come on. One, two, three...
-Hey!
[ Camera shutter clicks ]